this month last year the hard rock hotel
closed for good tonight the hotel and
casino at that site has been completely
renovated
and is now open as virgin hotels las
vegas
sasha loftis was on hand earlier for the
opening ceremonies
and shows us what the new property is
all about
well brian this property was definitely
worth the wait it had all the excitement
of a typical
las vegas party but those behind today's
events say
it is truly a symbol of what's to come
the doors are now unlocked this pivotal
moment
marks a brand new beginning
[Music]
virgin hotels las vegas officially
opened its doors thursday
bringing with it an extra dose of
fanfare
this is not your grandfather's old hotel
this is
this is a fun place the property which
was once the hard rock hotel
boasted a 200 million dollar renovation
with 1500 rooms and a 60 thousand square
foot casino space
and the first look inside was absolutely
electric
with new restaurants bars and a few
uncommon characters
it's the result of so many years of
incredible
dedication hard work on so many people's
behalf
but those behind this era of excitement
say it goes
far beyond the surface as an opportunity
to bring
just under 2 000 people back into the
workforce
seeing vegas open and people investing
in new hotels like this
is symbolic to say we're not out of the
woods yet
but we're over the worst so if you'd
like to come down and see what's new
get ready for a dose of this modern
desert oasis
that's looking to bring its own flair to
this already
fabulous community
[Applause]
now the only part of this property here
virgin hotels las vegas that's not
complete yet
is the day club and resort pool that is
set to complete here in this coming may
so we'll look forward to that
also something to note the mohegan sun
casino here at
the virgin property is actually the
first and only
tribally operated casino here in las
vegas
reporting live tonight sasha loftis 8
news now